CES starts tomorrow and runs through
Sunday the number of attendees are far
bigger this year as the pandemic still
slowed its return in 2022. Las Vegas
Convention Center and visitors Authority
president and CEO Steve Hill says this
year is starting out strong preparations
for this event started as early as
mid-December with the help of CES staff
and subcontractors CES is a huge part of
that the technology aspect of that also
is
exceptionally helpful to our reputation
here in Las Vegas is a serious place to
do business and a place for companies to
come and make that happen so it matters
a lot this is Brunswick corporation's
third year at CES the company
specializes in Marine Recreation vice
president of communications Lee Gordon
says a lot of work goes into what they
have on the showroom floor we've been
working on this for over a year so
there's a lot that goes into us because
for us we're really good at boat shows
we know what that looks like but we're
now on the playing level with Microsoft
and Mercedes and some of these other
companies that are just Global names
with more than 100 000 attendees and
nearly 3 000 exhibitors expected this
year Hill says Las Vegas has been named
the convention capital of the U.S and
there's a couple of reasons for that
obviously the covet is pretty much in
our rear view mirror we're back to
fairly normal Brian Cooley see net
editor at large agrees he's been
attending for 19 years now it's back to
what feels like a good healthy uh Vibe
on the floor they've been preparing
since fall for the big event and that'll
be a combination of sending a large team
here but also having our teams in New
York San Francisco also getting ready to
cover the show remotely
a reminder there is going to be a lot of
traffic in the area especially by the
convention center Paradise Desert Inn
wind and Resorts World very congested if
you work in the area remember to give
yourself a lot of extra time